それでは皆様 お待たせいたしました
ただ今より初期仏教入門始めさせていただきます
本日から仏弟子たちの歌を歌を読むと題しまして
4 5 6月3回お話をいただきます
もう皆様ご存じだとは思いますが
ご紹介させていただきます
スリランカ上座部仏教長老でいらっしゃいますアルボムレスマナサーラス先生です
ちょっと今パソコンの方の準備がありますけれども
整い次第お話いただきます
よろしくお願いします
では よろしくお願いいたします
えーと あまりあの 説明する必要はないと思いますけど
長老たちの例えばテーラワーダ
テーラワーダ テーラワーダと二つありましてね
学者がすごく古いというふうに思ってるんですけどね
まあ学者の意見としては大したことないんだけど
ただ詩でできているんだから古いというのはどういうわけかよくわからない
思っているのは この詩は書き換えることは難しいんだと
これはね 我々インド人のことをあまりにも知らなさすぎやと思います
我々にとっては普通のプロスよりは詩っていうのはいたって簡単に作れるんです
で 今の即興 その場で詩を作って講演までやる人々さえいるんです
だからサンスクリット
パーリ語であろうが まあ詩を学んでいればね
偈を作ると言うことはそんなに難しくはないんです
まあだから詩は変えられません
音節があるんだから あれは決まりがあるんだからとかね
ありますけど そんなのは我々にはもう遺伝子に入っているんだからね
ただちょっとハモるだけでわかります
ここ間違い ここはOKやと
まあとにかく 偈というのは
どちらが古くてどちらが新しいってことはね
そんなに簡単に決められるものでもないんですね
まあ一応学者の方々は古いなと勝手に思っているところ
私はそうとも思わない
えーと 古いところもあって
それほど古いと思う 古いと思えないもの
ところもあります はい
それであの 私は決めたわけじゃなくて
皆様方 自分の希望でいろいろテーマを決めるんだからね
なんか私はあの 何と言いますかね
荷車を運ぶ牛のようにね
みんな乗せた荷物を運んでいるだけで
だからなんであんたこの偈を選んだのかと
私に聞かないでください
で 日本 まあおそらく昨日気づいたんだけどね
おそらくこの中村先生の訳を読んで
みんなこれが良いと思うような感じがしますけどね
うん これはあの ジェンタ
テーラワーダ まずは2つに分けて説明します
今日は長老2人の説明なんです
だからテーラワーダというのは
この阿羅漢になったという人たちなんですね
だから自分が阿羅漢になって悟って
いかに人生の悩み苦しみを越えて安らぎに達したんでしょうかということを言うところで
で 直接私は阿羅漢になったというふうに言うところもあって
まあそうではなくて 間接的に言うところもありましてね
間接的に言うところ 私は古いと思いますね
うん で 直接やったぞ 阿羅漢になったぞという場合は
まあ誰かさんがこの長老の名前で偈を作って設定したこともあり得る
で 問題はこのテーラワーダ
テーラワーダ出てくるキャラはね
全て偉大なる方々なんですね
お坊さんたちと尼さんたちが
みんなすごい立派な方々で
立派っていうのは この偉い富豪かとかね
そんなものじゃなくて
社会 いろんなランクの人々が仏道に入っていかに立派になるのかっていうね
だからああいう 弟子たちと比丘尼たちは自分の性格で頑張れば誰だってすごいことをできるぞというようなことを言っている
この証拠ですね 仏道に対して
で 最初にこのジェンタッテーラカータっていうことで
原文ではプローヒタプッタという形容詞が入って
そうでないとちょっとなんか馴染みのない単語なんですね
ジェンタという名前は
この名前しかないんですね
パーリ経典では 別に不思議じゃないんだけど
普通あんまり我々は人にジェンタという名前は使いませんね
うん ジェンタっていうのはこの意味のある名前ですけどね
まあ勝った人 勝利者って意味なんですけどね
でもあまり人の名前に使わない
この人の個人的な名前はジェンタですね
この尊者の大阿羅漢のね
プルヒタプッタっていうのは
この家の名前が必要ですから
家の名前が落ちているんですね
だからお父さんのことをですね
あの まあこれはこれから説明します
はい プローヒタプッタという言葉の説明にいきます
プローヒタっていうのはたくさん意味のある単語で
先輩 師匠 アドバイザー
老師という意味なんで
老師は中国の老師ではなくてね
かなりの尊敬に対する師匠というね
プローヒタ プローヒタ単語の意味っていうのは
このリーダーという前にみんな来てくださいというね
いうような意味なんですね
それから国師 国王の司祭官という意味もあります
面倒くさいね いろんな意味あるんだから
だからコンテキストで取らなくちゃいけないんですね
総理大臣という意味もあります
総理大臣は別の意味ありますけど
で なんでこんなダブっちゃったってところ
全部一人が全部役やったことがあるんですよ
王のあの指導者としてね
アドバイザーとしている
王のアドバイザーだから
どうせ王様より年上なんですね
しかし 王様の方が立場上ですけどね
だからこの これこれやるなよっていうことをちょっと言えないんですよ
一般の人々には で 年上のプローヒタだったらやめた方がいいんじゃない？ということぐらいは言えるんですね
普通 総理大臣にパーリ語で別な名前ありますよ
その場合は まあ王様のこの
何といいますか この仕事をするメンバーたちなんですね
その時は王様が一番トップで
総理大臣もいるんですけど
総理大臣が自分の仲間を管理するし
それはマハマッチャというんですね
その場合は ウッタっていうのは子
息子っていう意味ですね
それでプロヒタブッタというのがわかりますね
ジェンタさんはコーサラ国王の主催官の息子でした
で コーサラ国だから相当の立場のある一番大きい国でしたしね
国で王様の次 すごい権力握っている人なんですね
王様にもいろいろアドバイスできる人だからね
それで当然バラモン人ですね
司祭官でもありますからね
宗教的なこともやらなくちゃいけないんだからね
はい さっさと中に入ります
カースト差別の問題 で
このエピソードはこのカーストの問題なんです
皆さんも知ってるでしょう
ジェンタさんっていうのはバラモンカーストの一番トップなんですね
インド社会では あ また間違ってます
これバラモン教っていうのはこの教じゃなくて教えではね
カースト意識は社会差別を超えたもので
精神的 宗教的な考えも入ってます
だいたい私もそういうことをやってきましたけど
このけしからんやと カースト差別はね
仏教 ブッダの立場からね
人間みんな平等ではないかとかね
人を差別するなんてそんなこと言ってますけど
インドのカーストシステムがなかなかなくならないんです
それはこの階級制度にこの宗教的な意味合いが入ってるんですね
だからヒンドゥー教の哲学者たちがみんな同じ平等ですべて一つであると
現象的にバラバラに見えても
真理は一つだよというふうに言ってるんだから
頭でっかちのところから見ればみんな平等ですけど
でもそれで神がそれぞれの魂の成長のためにプログラムを組んでるんですね
魂の状況を見て じゃああのプログラムやってください
このプログラムやってくださいというふうにプログラムを組むみたいですね
ですから 人間がいろんなところで
いろんな職業で いろんな家で生まれちゃう
生まれたらそこはもう神様がもう塾に入れたところだから
その仕事をすることはもうやらな
神に対して自分の義務を果たすことになるんですね
だから日本でも人気のあるこの
何て言ったっけ あの文学作品は
このバガヴァッドギーター
これはインド人にとっては宗教の書ですけど
普通の人 あれはただの文学作品ですけどね
バカでかいマハバーラタって文学作品があって
それのワンチャプター
バガヴァッドギーターなんですね
だから文学作品としては相当なもんなんですけどね
現代人には書けないぐらいすごいもんですけど
で 神話いっぱい入れちゃってね
その中ですごく綺麗に人生論やら哲学やらいろんなものが入ってるんですね
すごく面白く読める その中で一つのチャプター
一つの場面がバガヴァッドギーターなんですね
誰でしたっけ あれはね
アルジュナ その対話なんですね
で そちらでも今ヒンドゥー教の聖書みたいになってますけど
この社会差別を認めるんですね
これは余計なことを言うなよと
すべて神が決まって 神が仕事を
義務を与えているんですね
だから神に与えられた義務を文句言わずに果たしなさいと
そういうことだから このすごく低いカーストの人々も
上のカーストの人々に文句言ってはならないと
文句言うことは 自分が神に与えられた仕事をやってないことになるんですね
で だからインド人に 訳も分からない神様がいるんだから訳も分からないまま
どんなやつを神と思って考えてるかよく分からないんですね
最初はブラフマという神でしたけど
すごく早くも捨てちゃったんです
なぜならばブラフマ神っていうのはすごい大人しくて
あんまり人間がやってることにはガチャガチャ関わり持たない
離れている 神のところに行きたければ修行しなさいと
こんなやつはいらんやと
もっと女を犯すは強盗するはいい加減な神様いっぱい作っちゃったんですね
それで文学者 文学者たちがストーリー作るんですよ
作ったら普通みんなそれが宗教書だと思ってるんですね
このラーマのラーマーヤナというラーマシータ物語で結構人気あるんですね
だからその中で文学が 2つ
2つありましてね で 一番文学的に一番トップグレードの我々サンスクリット語を学ぶ時学ぶテキストはワルミキという師匠が書いたラーマーヤナなんですね
もう完璧なサンスクリット語で素晴らしい詩なんですね
しかし だらしないトレスダスという人が書いたラーマーヤナはちょっと古いんだけど
あるんですね だからそれはインド人の宗教書なんですね
ワルミキのものじゃないんですね
で 変なものを論理的でないものを
くだら物をいっぱい入れちゃって
ワルミキ人はそうじゃなくて
現代人でも驚くほどの作品を作ったんですね
現代も何でも驚きますよ
あの能力は 文学作品は何で現実事実だと思うのかっていうことは問題なんですね
そういうことで いろんな神々がいてね
ラーマ神はラーマ神を拝んだりする場合もあるし
クリシュナを拝んだりする場合もあるし
で 困った時は人を助けるのはヴィシュヌ神ですけど
一部の人々しかヴィシュヌを信仰してないんですね
だからヒンドゥー教っていうのはもうどうしても取り扱いしにくい宗教で
で 本山とか何もないんですね
ヒンディ教のこの人はトップで偉いっていうことはね
教祖様みたいな教皇みたいな存在はないんです
ないんだけど しっかり元気なんですね
ということは 誰だって自分勝手に何か宗教を作ればいいんです
誰もそれを否定する 非難する権利はありませんね
それで バラモンカーストの人々は
自分たちが一番トップのカーストで
神との関わりを持つなさいという仕事で作られたと
だからすごいかっこよくて心を育てているとか
勝手なことを言ってるんですね
それで自分たちが神の直々の作られたものだから
もう何やってもいいやという態度をとっているんですね
自分以外 宗教儀式儀礼だったらバラモンカーストの人でしかできませんと
だからインド人はもうそんなこと言ったってもやってないんですよ
でも結婚式の時はね 誰かバラモンのカーストの人呼んでね
誰でも覚えている文 マントラありますよ
それ唱えて回を回って
それで終わり そいつはいくら金もらってもうそれで帰ります
別に宗教家ではない カーストバラモンであればそれで十分なんです
他はもう自分勝手に宗教やってます
そこで私はこの最近いろいろ普通学者が調べない
調べられないインドの社会について
別な手段でいろいろデータ取っているんですね
結構 それでももう私はインド社会って
まぁなんだこれやとどうにも手に負えないというね
いろんな問題があって
みんな問題はわかってるんだけど
どうにもならない 自由がない社会でありながら自由もあると
なんか変です 例えば不可触民族
低いジャータとかね いろいろカーストのはもう社会にも入れてくれませんよ
それでも現代的にしっかり頑張っちゃって
無理やりでも学校に入って勉強して知識人になっちゃったら
まあ邪魔だという感じでね
誰も何もことができなくなっちゃうんです
で ネールさんはすごくすごくあのカースト制度あれこれとものすごい反対な人格者でしたけどね
インドの最初の首相はね
でも彼には彼の考え通りに一つもできなかったそうです
インドブラマン人がもうとにかく邪魔して
カースト制度を完全消えますと
あんたそこまで強引に言うならば
じゃあ法律で決めてください
でも我々やりますよ だからインド法律では
憲法ではカースト差別は禁止ですけど
その日からのはずだけとやってるんです
しかし 低いカーストの人に頑張って大金持ちになれないかとなります
なったらその人の下でバラモン人も仕事をします
イギリス植民地にやられた時は
イギリス植民地っていうのは
このイースインド会社でしたからね
恐ろしいこと金儲けだけで国をハチャメチャにしちゃって
好き勝手に人を殺したり
人の土地を奪ったりとかね
彼らが彼らになんかインド人がすごい協力しちゃったね
逆に なぜかというと このイギリスから来た白人たちっていうのはろくでもない人間
みんな 紳士って言ってる一人もいない
それでこの何差別？この白人だけ優れているんだと
インド人を綺麗に差別するんですね
インド人腹立つべきなんですけど
私はスリランカ人みたいに
それはないんですね わかってます
カースト差別とは だからあれはホワイトカーストなんですね
だからそのカーストの人々はそういう肉食ったり
いろんなことをやっているグループで
それはやらせてくださいと
いうことで このバラモン人は知識人ですね
学者なんですね みんな
ものすごい勉強する だからお父さんが勉強家だからね
息子は当然 そこでこの言語能力はかなり優れてますね
インド文化は で インドにこのウルデュ語とかね
ペルシャーンランゲージとかね
このアラビア文化も入ってましたから
どんな言語もすごいできるんです
だから いたって簡単に英語は学ぶんですね
だからイギリス人にとってはものすごい簡単に便利で雇われる人間なんですね
カーストサービスもできるし
この連中はもうまあ 1つぐらい 6つ
4つぐらい言葉を喋れる
支配者の白人たちには教育も何もない
ただのもう犯罪者なんですね
イギリスでは 楽にやっと自分の名前を書ける程度の能力で
でも雇っている人々はそうじゃなくて
相当な知識のある人間
そういうことでいろいろインドの社会でね
不思議な そういうところで学べたのは
私は分かったのはこの
このカースト制度っていうのはかなりややこしくて
それは宗教になっているところなんですね
だから宗教は個人で ヒンドゥ教ではね
宗教はあくまでもグループのグループのことじゃないんです
日本の新興宗教団体とはもう全く違う
一人が自分の好きなように自分の宗教を信仰すればいいんです
決まり いろいろお祭りとかあります
その時は誰だって祭りには参加しますが
参加するかしないかは自分勝手でよろしいし
どのように参加するか自分で決めればいいし
どのように修行すれば自分で決めればよろしいし
それでこのバラモン人とこのシャミンダルというもうシャトリエ色ですね
パーリ語で言えばね 我々は王家とか何とか訳しますけど
また地主族なんですね
土地持ってる全部 だから王は一番土地
国の全体的に持ってるんだから王家になっているんだけど
別に王家ってわけじゃないんですね
一応たくさん土地を持ってる人はラージャーと言って王様扱いがするんです
あの連中もバラモン人もどちらが偉いかということで競争がありまして
結局王家の連中は金持ちだから
あの連中はもうバラモンを雇ってしまうんですね
だからバラモン人が勝手に自分たちが優れていると思ったとしても
勝手にしなさいと 現実は違うでしょうと
そこで面白いことは この自分でカースト制度を決めたら
どのようにカーストを守るのかと
カーストを汚してはいけない
カーストを汚しちゃうと
すると自分なんか宗教からはみ出されたというふうに怖がるんです
例えば優しい人で 人間はみんな同じだと思ったとしても実行できません
実行しちゃう 自分のカーストで決まってる
しきたり破っちゃうでしょ
そうすると宗教家はもう
はみ出されたことになっちゃうんですね
自分の信仰から これは組織宗教じゃないんだからよりきついんですね
自分自身で異端者になったような感じなんです
そうするとキリスト教にならなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
そのインドの人々は キリスト教もこの異端宗教だと見ていないんですね
それもあり得ると 神はいろんな顔を持ってますからっていうことで
それで皆様に言いたいことはこれなんですけど
例えば自分がこの聖潔性カーストを守ると思うと
自分が着る服は自分の親戚
親兄弟 そういう家族の誰かが洗わなきゃダメとかね
あるいはそのカーストで洗濯カースト決めてあって
その洗濯カーストの人々が洗わなくちゃいけないと
もし誰かが自分のカースト以外の人が自分を触ったら
だからインド人は握手しないんです
昔はこの植民地時代でも
だって白人違うカーストだからね
白人カーストだから握手しない
どうしても白人がやっぱし何だお前と握手したらすぐ行って体清めるんです
沐浴して それみんなじゃなくて勝手に決めるんですね
誰かが左手で自分を触ったら
直ちに行って沐浴しないと
してもう体清めなくちゃいけない
そこで自分の家でいろんなカーストの人々は仕事をするでしょ
いくら何でもその道具触らない
例えば掃除すると箒とかいろいろ便所を掃除すると使う道具とかあったら
それは目に入るところにでも置いてはいけません
まあハチャメチャなんですね
だからそれはみんな守るかと
そうでもない 自分勝手に決める
例えば肉を食べるか食べないかとか
勝手に決めるのはよろしい
バラモンとこのクシャトリヤカースト以外は肉を食べなさいとも言ってるんですね
あんた方は労働しますから
最近もインドのこういう宗教家たちの話を聞いてると
やっぱり結局同じことを言ってるんですね
現代人だろうと だから体に一番いい食べ物は何なのかとという
結構知識人で ある意味ではなんか仙人扱いされている人なんですけど
で 口達者だけでね すごい英語も達者でね
説法はしますけどね 聞いてみると
自分の仕事に適した食べ物を食べなさいと
いっぱい例を出すんですね
だから肉食いの魚食べるなよではないんですね
例えば重労働する人だったら
その仕事に適した食べ物を食べなさいと
何も仕事をしないで贅沢な人々は
まあそれも自分の生き方に適した食べ物を食べなさいと
それを間違っちゃうと
現代人みたいにみんな同じこと食っちゃ
それはあかんやと いう話ですね
だから私は昔から同じことやとお前もっていう感じで聞いてるんですけどね
服装の迷信で成り立っているし
人によって変わったカースト感覚を持っています
だからこのあるある迷信あるんですね
この仏典で出てくる一つのエピソードがありまして
あるバラモン人が自分の家にあった服をネズミに噛まれてネズミに噛まれたら
これはものすごい不浄
触れちゃうとカーストが下げるんですね
おかしい だからあの頭でっかちの神がいるでしょ
頭象嵌の 知ってるでしょ？ガネーシャというんですね
知恵の商売の神ですけど
知恵であれ動物ですよ
頭がね まあ象さんは普通動物の中で頭いいとは思いますけどね
もう町中見せてみたい
ただ昔 志賀神がね 腹が立ってね
ワイフは奥さん置いといてどこか出て行くんですよ
出て行って もうもう何百年も出て行って分からない
で で 帰ったらこの自分の奥さんの髪がもう子供だったんです
まだお父さん見たこともない
こいつも大きくなってるんですね
それで私は寝るんだだろうね
お母さんがお前ちゃんと誰も入らないようにいてくださいと言うと
この若い子がね よしわかったと
お母さんを守ってる それでお父さんが来たんです
見たこともない すごい見た目ではかっこがある
志賀神がどこかで修行に入っていたんですね
だから変な気持ち悪い格好で
なんでお前は帰るんだよ
だからこの神怒っちゃって
お前何やと 志賀神すっごい偉いんだからね
ぶん殴っちゃったんですね
息子を ぶん殴ったら首が飛んじゃったんです
で 奥さんの部屋に入っちゃうとどうだと
そしたら あ お前来たのかと
お前会ったことないでしょ
私の前の息子にと 会ったの？会ってない
なんかうるさい奴がいたんだけど
首を切っちゃったんだと
帰ろうと言うと邪魔するやなんて
何様なのつもりだよ 私はかっこいい神の方だからね
言ったら奥さんがすっごく驚いて
何それ？これがお前の息子です
なんとかしてよ でも何とかすることもできなくて
色々迷信であれでこれでなんか北の方
頭入れてる誰かの首を持ってこなさいみたいなことでゾウさん見つけてゾウさんの首を持ってきて付けたってそうですね
で まあそれ信じてるんだから
本当に今の連中は まあ一人一人面白いよ
一人一人として決して悪くないんです
だって現代も息子の顔知らない父親って結構いるんだから
だからあの だから何でいいんだかなって言ってゾウの首をつけちゃってね
そこでこのガネーシャ神はこのネズミの乗りのネズミなんですね
それで悪口言っちゃうとね
なんか新しい話になるみたいです
だってネズミの上に乗れる？あんなでっかい体を
まあカピバラで言った方がいいんだと思いますけど
カピバラネズミですけども乗れないね
まあ神のご登場だからあり得るということで OK なんですけどね
なんか新しい話になるんだけど
忘れちゃったそれはね
えーと 現代人に納得いけるバージョン今書いているみたいですけど
で なんか神の乗り物だから別にネズミが不浄な動物じゃないはずなんですね
ではこのバラモン 仏教に出てくるバラモン人の時代では
もしかするとガネーシャの話ができてなかった可能性もあります
今もヒンドゥー教の神々の物語
ずっと新しく作って作って持っていくんだからね
だからこのバラモンがとんでもない不浄なものを着たと
言って長い棒を持ってて
触ったらあかんだからね
あの服をね このまま取って持っていくんです
墓場に捨てる そのと そこでお釈迦様かどれかのお坊さんかとわからないんだけど
これ狙っていたんです
これ長い棒で持っていくんです
言って で この出家者がいるんですけど
それはあまり気にしないで
本人がこれ服を捨てて
それから体を清めなくちゃいけないので川に入って一番体清らかになるのはガンジス川なんですね
あるいはガンジス川近くのガンジス川に入る小川いるあるんだから
どこかでね いくつかの決まってる川があるんですね
世界一汚れてる川ですけど
世界一心が清らかになるんですよ
ガンジス川っていうのはね
痛いも半分焼いちゃってそのまま投げ捨ててるんだからね
この考えでいたところで
この人 あの坊主 あの 石持って服を捨てたんですね
捨てた瞬間で出家にそれを拾うことができます
これ待って待ってるんですね
石持って持ってる間は
その人のものなんです
で ゴミ箱に遺体捨て場のところに行って
ポツンと捨てたらもう本人のものじゃないんですね
バラモン人が待っているところでバッサバッサとそれを拾っちゃったんです
だからこの仏教がこのバラモン人の迷信にものすごく反対しているという意味でもありますね
しかし この人 優しい人でね
触るなよと あなたに子供の服が必要だったらね
まあ宗教は違うんだけど
私はあげたと こんな不浄なもの
あなた心が汚れますよ
言ったらそれに文句言ってね
我々にとっては一番清らかな服はこういうものよ
捨てちゃいけないと 言って
最終的に世界いろいろ行って帰ったそうでね
そういうわけで どんどんバラモン人も仏教徒になっていったんですよ
仏教徒になったとはカースト捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
だからカーストは宗教になってるんです
宗教がカーストになることっておかしいね
でも皆様に現代で言い出しちゃうとおかしくないと思いますよ
例えばこのキリスト教の方々に聞いてください
天国に行くのは誰ですか？イエスを信仰する人だけでしょう
他みんなもう地獄に落としちゃうんです
それもカースト差別ですよ
うちの神を信じなかったら人間に荒らすとイスラム教ははっきり言ってます
言わない 読んでみてください
我々は信じてない連中はもう動物と同じ
言っちゃったらまずいんだから言わないだけ
だから言っちゃうで他宗教の人を殺したりするんです
そこで人間もそれなりに頑張ってますから
今はありがたいんですね
自分たちで自分たちを殺っているんだ
イエス イエス よく頑張ってください
で 何か訳で殺す スンニ派とシーア派でもお互い殺してもいいんです
だからちょっと宗教の宗派が違うだけでも殺すんだから
いわゆる人間らしくしてないでしょ
これはインドのカースト差別とはもっと汚いんでしょ
人間とは殺したりはしませんね
触ってもいけないんだからね
だからこのどんな宗教でもちょっと行って聞いてみてください
うちのことを信仰じゃなかったらね
あんたアウトだと言うでしょ
それはカーストなんですね
ひどいのはもうだって「おかしいね」とかね
程度じゃなくてこの栄誉
人格まで落としちゃうんだから
別に落とすわけじゃないんだけど
これ気持ち だから宗教っていうのは一切差別のないものでなければいけませんね
イエスはそんなような言葉を言ったような
言ってないようなってことあるんだけど
学者によると結局はもうイエスあるある 200年 250年前に仏教がもうその国々に行ったんだから
エジプトやらメソポタミアやらイギリス
ギリシャとかね その教えが入っちゃって
ギリシャ哲学も変わっちゃってね
仏教はね 少なかったんだけど
教えが教えられたものが入っちゃってね
だからそれは学者の間で学ぶんだから
聖書っていうのは作品でしょ
聖書も 新約聖書っていうのはたくさんあったんですよ
もう 300ぐらい それをもう勝手に 23冊とかってことでね
勝手にそこから捨てちゃったんですね
だからそんなに当てにならないんですけどね
で そういうふうにあるにも関わらず
ローマ教会はすごいカースト意識で
ローマ教をローマ教でローマ・カトリックというね
教えを広げてるんですね
結婚禁止なんです カトリックでなければ
カトリック以外の人と結婚するならば
その人は必ずカトリックにならなくちゃあかんとか
カースト制度ですか 別に決まってやって
もうどうしようもなく今変わってるんです
だからこのインドのカースト制度に対してね
非道いということはちょっとイスラムでもやってるんですよ
だからブッダの考えで
これって人類の普遍的な問題であるというふうに見なくちゃあかんですね
どうでも差別してあると
そういうわけで 我々みたいなインド人でない人にとっては
ヒンドゥー教は理解することはできないんです
我々の友達になった人の仕来り習慣
なるほど ヒンドゥー教でこんなことやるのかといったら
別な人友達だったら違うことやっちゃう人です
だから なかなかこれってわからないんですね
カーストに関わる生き方が自分個人の宗教観であり
修行でもありますから
カースト制度そのものがカーストを守ることが
そういう方々にとっては修行なんですね
バラモンについてちょっと説明しましょう
カーストのしきたりを守って
救国の精神のの清浄を期待しているんですね
だからバラモン カーストの人々は学者でありながら政治活動もしながら
で 商売は商売 たまにやったりするんで
あんまりやらないんだけど
王様からがっぷり金もらっちゃうんですね
王様とすごい金持ちから
勉強頭だからね 仕方がないんですね
商人にしたっても 会計士としてバラモン陣営頭ないとどうにもならん
だから給料もらったりはするんですね
はい 彼らがこの自分のこのカーストで決まったしきたりをね
しっかり守って そのしきたり守ることによって心が清らかになるっていうふうに思っているんですね
一旦この山に掛かったら
立ち直りは不可能ですよ
女性の方々その気持ちはわかると思いますよ
何か気持ち悪いと思ったらどうしようもないでしょ
例えばゴキブリ嫌いな人がいるでしょ
ゴキブリは別にコバみたいな凶暴でもコバみたいな凶暴でも何でもないんだけどね
人間がもうすぐ逃げちゃうしね
一途たりとも攻撃しないんです
でもゴキブリ見ただけでも飛び上がっちゃって
もうすごい泣き叫んでもしょうがないんですね
そういう人もいる そうでない人もいる
だからあれって説明できんでしょ
で それたらびっくりする人もいるし
ヘビ見ただけで全員もう怖くなってもう息も止まるぐらいなる人もいたりとかね
病気ですよ だから私のようにどんなどうやっても何のことなくへっちゃらっていう感じにはならないんですね
だから まあ日本的な例で言えば
例えばこのご飯持った茶碗にね
箸を立てちゃうとどう？食べる？絶対食べないね
そういうことなんです
何の意味もないね 結局は
別にご飯持った茶碗に箸を立てておく
だからご飯壊れる 箸が壊れる
毒が生える 何でもないんです
でももう食べませんね
そういうのはいくらでもあります
インド教で 日本でもあると思いますけど
私はそんな面白くないんだから
日本の文化はね もうややこしくないしね
だからあんまり勉強する気持ちはなかったんだけどね
今更年寄り 私はそんなこと勉強しても意味がないでしょ
私はもう今正式にどれどれ金がこの葬式が決まっちゃった方がいいんだからね
マジそれだけ考えてるんで
あと何年ですかとか だから
こんなことやらない 面白いことですよ
でもあれ宗教的な感覚が入っちゃうと
もう仕方がない もう治らない
だからこういう風に これ色々この迷信っていうのは宗教と関わって持ってくると病気になるんです
精神的に これ仏教は直しますよ
だって例えば私もご飯あまり食べませんだけど
ご飯茶碗に盛ったら箸を刺すことは決してしません
それは別の意味でかっこ悪い
でもたまたま忙しくてなんとなくやってる場合はね
何かご飯食べてくださいと話が合っても
じゃあいいやということでやる場合もあります
誰もいないんだからね
だからちょっとかっこ悪いんじゃないって程度だったら病気にならない
箸をね 箸置きに置く場合も形式でやるんですね
それに宗教的な意味合いが入っちゃうと
精神的に病気になる それで理性的に意味入れてみてください
箸を入れる場合は 箸置きには箸の先っぽ置くでしょ
逆にはしたことがある？やってみてよと
人間自由だから 何でやりづらいね
だからそういうこの子供たちやってることすごくいいことなんですよ
これはもう今までわからないんだから
とんでもないことやっちゃうでしょ
あれすごく勉強してください
心が自由になるんです
行儀悪いことをやりなさいではなくて
勉強してほしい 例えば箸置き 2つ持って
その上に箸を乗せるとかね
するとおかしく感じちゃうんだけど
でも長い何とか箸そのまま入れる入れ物あるんです
長いもので そこで箸をちゃんと置く
置きますよ で 箸を立てませんだけど
中華料理屋ではね なんか便利で全部箸を立てたままで
中国と韓国では 箸を立てるんです
日本でも何となくやってますよ
たくさんの箸がある 全部揃って
何かにカップか何かに入れておく
はい だって箸を配るはね
やっぱりほとんど人間が右利きだから右の方で
あの手で触るところだから
それはもうテーブルに触れております
ご飯食べるところだから
ちょっと汚れないようにと置いてますよという論理的な意味合いを入れておいてください
こういう意味合いのこと
別にこれ逆にしたからって死ぬわけじゃないんだよと
あるいは箸を日本も逆さまにしてもね
逆にこうやってね 立っても大丈夫です
死にませんわね まあそんなことじゃないで揃っておきなさいと
西洋の場合はナイフとフォークとかね
まあいろいろ入れる左か右かあるでしょうにね
まあただ常識にしなきゃダメなんです
そんなの でなきゃすごい精神にかかってくるんです
だから文化を宗教的に
しきたり習慣は決して宗教的にしてはいけません
精神的な病気になります
だからこのバラモン人にとっては
これはひどいもんでしょう
だから一番トップカーストと思っていて
カーストの決まりがあって
絶対他人の家で水飲めませんよ
ご飯食べない バラモン人が水をこの井戸からは
他のカーストの人と水を汲んだらもう大変なことになる
殺される 殴られる だって
お前ら汚いんだから井戸を汚すなよと
だからあっち行きなさいと言ったら
まあそれはあまりいい言葉じゃないんだけど
まあ仕方がないと許してあげることはできます
宗教的に井戸が不浄になったっていうことが腹が立ちますね
今日理解してほしいのは
この宗教的に宗教的な意味合いを入れている
そういう迷信 キリスト教でも結構あります
仏教 ジャイナ教と一部のヒンドゥー教の思想家も反対したが
インド社会では消えない問題です
カースト制度にはインドでもインドでも反対する人はいます
昔だったら仏教はもう大反対
ジャイナ教もカースト制度はないんです
インド教でもカーストは良くないと語っている哲学者がいるんです
でも消えない 問題はそれない
はい ジェンタの特徴に行きましょうか
国王の司祭官の息子で
これ読めない  美貌  美貌
財産 知識 体力 権力などなどの何でもそろっていたと
この人は バラモン教ではバラモン人のバラモンのカーストの場合は美しい美男であること
美女であることも一つの決まりなんです
とは言うんだけど 私はなかなかバラモンカーストの中で美男なんだか見たことがないんです
みんなごっつい気持ちも悪くないんだけど
普通のジジイばっかりで
なんでそんなこと思うのかはよくわからない
殺陣職人は結構いるんだけどね
美しい女性も男性も この人全部揃っていたんですね
この人は 1年前になると周りの人が嫌悪を感じ始めたんです
この若者が自分な自分特有の宗教観を持っていたと思います
これは注釈書もここら辺まで進んでないんです
だから中村元先生のテキストで仏教を学んでいる人よりは
私は全く間違っていることを言うと
中村先生に反抗しているんだからね
そうかもしれませんだけどね
本当に知らない世界が結構あるんです
私は注釈書を見たんだけど
分かってないなと この若者が
極々贅沢な生き方で司祭官の息子だから
ものすごい金持ちなんです
で それですごい体力もある
すごい美男だったらバラモンカーストでしょう
だから自分がいろいろ宗教観
カーストの宗教をね 一人で作るんだから
作ってみて これは私はやりません
あれはやりません あれと決めたところで
どんどんみんな馬鹿に見えちゃうんですね
これってこの大体男性には若い時あることなんですよ
この 20歳から 30歳まで男っていうのはみんなみんなバカやと思っているんですね
自分の師匠やら親やらね
なんてアホな親ですかとかね
それは後で直ります 私も何も隠さずそう思っていたんですけど
なんていうバカですか
だからどんな男にもかかる病気にかかっちゃったんですよ
俺は何でも知っている
俺は何でも完璧にやる
それにしたら何だこれは
とかね もしかすると自分の父親が司祭官でもありながら政治家のトップでしょう
総理大臣みたいな感じでしょ
だからいろんな人と喋ったり
話したり いろんなことをやらなくちゃいけない
王様 王様がさんが あの
名前はプラセジなんですけど
コーサラ国ですね コーサラ国王はバラモン人じゃないんですね
でも礼を教えなくちゃいけないし
頭下げなくちゃいけないし
だから息子から見れば
なんでこのじじいはもうカーストに
もうカースト汚れるんじゃないかと思ったでしょうね
若い時は でも自分も年取って仕事に行ったら同じことやらなくちゃいけないんだけどね
だからジェンタさんにとってはもうみんな卑しくてたまらん
誰を敬うことをしなかったんです
あなたに頭下げるなと
あんたこんなことやってるんだからと
あなた違うカーストの人と肩で触ったでしょうに
もうあなたとはもうという感じに
注釈書はただの傲慢として理解していますけど
ただの傲慢じゃないんですよ
かなり精神的な大きな問題なんです
釈尊に会うんで この人は
公で説法する釈尊に会って立ったままでいたんですね
もし釈尊が私に話をしたしたら
私は返事します 彼が先に話さなかったらそのまま帰ります
よくわからない お釈迦様がこんなに大きなテーマとか知られてたんです
すごい説法していますと
ものすごい素晴らしいこと
いろんなこと見解があります
何でも知りたそうに様は本当に何でも知りだから
この人はもうじゃあ自分の問題聞こうかなと
この人もしかすると知ってるかなと
行ったんです 行っても俺は先に喋りません
お釈迦様にお願いします
質問あります そんなこと言ったらもうカースト
カーストの決まりで破ったことになります
だってブラマン人でない人にお教えを請うとね
これバラモンカーストにとってはもうできませんね
皆様がゴキブリが見たら逃げるような感じで
だから本人がもう でも向こうが話したら話します
立ったままでいるんですよ
わざわざと 釈尊は本人に語らなかったので
そのまま帰るふりをしたんです
それを説法してるんですね
そういう人語れません
喋れません うん で 帰ろうかなとかね
なんか態度でかいよとにかく
いて立っていて 面白くない
帰るとか ものすごくもう若い
わかりやすい若者若者でしょ
大体男の場合はそんな感じでしょ
いつでも 親や大人が行きなさいと言ったら行くんですけど
ちょっとじゃあ俺が帰る
また帰っちゃう どうにもならない
ある時期があるんですね
でお釈迦様一応語ったんです
もう帰ろうとしたんだから
でもお釈迦様の言葉っていうのはかなり違う
ナ・マーナン・バーフマナ・サードゥ・アッティカッスィータ・バーフマナ
イエナ・アッテーナ・アーダッチー・タメヴァ・アヌブルーヘー
これはサンユッタニカーヤの
バラモンよ 傲慢は良くない
何かを知りたくて来たでしょう
それを聞いてみなさい
大体ああいう人っていうのは
この思春期とかね 男のこのどうにもならない年っていうのは
私はすごく可愛いと思いますよ
頑固なんですけど よく言うこと聞くんです
それでも 親だけ親には言えないだけでね
だからものすごい親に時々捨てられますよ
その時期ではね もう扱えません
もうダメですよとかね
私がいただくんで大体2日だけでです 2
日でものすごい子になるんです
でお釈迦様は同じやり方やったんですよ
お前態度でかいということで
態度でかすぎお前は これだったら何にもならんよと
いう話ですよ 普通の我々の世界の話ダウンしてみると
態度でかいお前はね それで何でもならんでしょ
知りたいこといろいろあるでしょうにと
聞いたらどうですか？という感じなんですね
バラモンは心に問題があったのです
それを釈尊が分かっていたんですね
だからこれは注釈書にないところで
私はこのいろんなインド社会状況
いろんな他のところから学んでみたんだから
そこからまあ推測して言ってますけど
この若者が 単純な頑固じゃないんで
単純な傲慢でもなくても
自分の性癖だからね それやっていて引っかかっちゃって生きづらくなっちゃったんですね
誰にも頭下げたくはないし
下げたくはないじゃなくて
自分の基準から見れば
この人に頭を下げる必要はない
自分が人の話を聞きたいんだけど
自分の基準 自分勝手に決めたものだから
ヒンドゥー教だからね
この人の話は誰が聞く？という感じでいるんですね
だからみんなを軽視して敬遠してるんだけど
本人それが喜んでるわけでもないんですね
だからものすごい精神的な悩みがあったんですね
あるんだけど 聞けない人に
あまりにも慢だから カーストの慢
だからすぐサンユッタニカーヤでこれバレちゃったんだからね
バレるほどじゃなくて
大体そんなもんだから
もう何か問題を抱えてるんですよ
頭とかね 特に女性も同じですけど
この年頃になってくると
いろんな精神的な問題あるんですね
でも親に聞かない お母さんに言わない
お父さんに言わない 先生に言わない
黙っている態度あるんです
行っちゃえば行ったって簡単だって
そこを年の人々から見ればもう可愛いし
もうそろそろ大人の世界に入るでしょうに
だから全面的に協力してあげたいとは思ってるんだけど
この連中聞かないんですね
一人で解決しようと思ってるんです
それで一人で解決できるわけじゃないし
これでこじれちゃうと人生全て台無しなんですね
これって人間という種の問題です
そこでお釈迦様じゃあ何か傲慢だったらあんた何もならんかと
聞いただったら聞いたど
言っちゃうと質問するんです
自分の精神の悩みを読まれたので
彼が喜びを感じ 釈尊に礼をし
質問します それで礼をしたんです
今まで親にも礼をしなかった
このアホが この頑固者が
お釈迦様だけ自分がただ頑固ではなくて
えらい真剣な人間であることわかったんですね
もうこの人はわかっている私の心を
だからまあ礼をしないとちゃんと
礼をしたんです 質問するんです
ケースのマナンカイラートケースチャットサガーラをキャッサーアプチターアッスーキャッサーサードスプージター
これでテキストのちょっとした間違いあったんだけど
テキストはそのまま言ってるんだけど
私は直してないんです
これ彼の質問なんですね
誰に傲慢張ってはならない
誰に頭下げる 誰に敬意を持つ
誰を尊敬すればよろしい
これは本人の問題なんですよ
周りから言われるわ 言われるわ言われるわ
でも自分が決めた宗教観から
おい たとえ親は親を敬いなさいと言ってはいるんだけど
こんな親誰が敬う？という感じになっちゃうんです
年上のバラモン人にちゃんと席を立って挨拶しない
あんな連中誰がやる？という態度を取っていたんですね
やりたくないではないんだかったんですね
自分が考えたあの宗教観が精神的な足かせになっていたんです
だからこの質問でよくわかりますよ
だからこのところ注釈書でもうちょっと説明した方が良かったなと思いますけどね
だから中村先生必要なところじゃないんですよ
歌詞書かれている注釈書にはちょっと問題があるんです
なんか私の若かりし頃みたいな感じで
まだまだ癖が直ってないみたいです
マータリピタリチャーティアトーゼッタンミバータリアーチャーリーチャトゥタムミーサマナブラフマネスチャー
ブッダの答え ブッダが何の事なく淡々と答える
両親 年上の兄弟 これは日本ではわからないんだけど
私たちの文化ではね 兄弟の年上はものすごい立場がありますよ
敬語使いも私も 師匠の沙門バラモンたちです
それでこの沙門バラモンと言ったら
この同じ俺もバラモンじゃないかっていう感じじゃないんです
バラモンの中でもあえていろいろ宗教的に修行する真剣なバラモンたちもいる
在家にどっしり入って在家生活ばっかりやってるバラモンたちもいる
自分好みであれば 修行的な生活をしてもよろしい
大体年取ってくると修行に入っちゃうんです
その中で沙門というグループがいて
バラモンというグループがいるんです
だからあれこれサマナブラフマナ
沙門バラモンというのは
この俗世間ではなく 俗世間から離れて宗教に精神的な修行に励んでいるグループなんですね
ああいう人々に尊敬しないと
師匠 日本はどうか分かりませんけれど
私たちの世界では学問は私はインド人じゃないんだけど
師匠敬わないと学問なり立たないんです
師匠敬いますよ いつでも
今私の師匠ってみんな亡くなられてるんだけど
それでももう会った時はものすごい私の態度は変わるんです
タイどこかの本山で大学で色々勉強を教えた先生がいて
出てびっくりしちゃって
先生すごいお年になっちゃってね
私ももうかなり大物になっていたんだけど
さっさと行って床にそのまま座って礼をして
先生お元気ですか？とお前何するの？こっちが立ってこっちが座れ座れとかね
何がだって怒られたんですね
だから他の立場のない連中はいろんな椅子に座っていたんですね
やっぱり私の場合は教えた先生だから
もうそちらでプライド張るとかね
一緒に並べて座るとかとんでもないことまで
だから床に座って で やっぱりそれはもう自分の国の文化もね
結局はインド文化は同じ文化だからね
師匠は敬うんですよ 師匠は
師匠はいつだってもう名前を何て言いますか
切り捨てて すっかりなんか乱暴に呼ぶんですよ
俺はすごい大好きなんですね
なんか先生たちが自分にちょっと社会的な立場を考えて
何かさんとか君とか入れちゃうとまずくて
まずいなと思っちゃうんですね
何もなくなんかもうキャラ安くされるとすごい気持ちが良くなってくる
だからそういう文化なんですね
テースナマーナンカイラートゥーテースアッササガーレオー
この行目キャッサプジタースというところでKは間違っています
が 私には直す権利はありません
これはPでなければいけません
読みに行きましょう この種類の人々に傲慢にならない
頭を下げる 敬意を持つ
尊敬する お釈迦様が言ったんだ
そんなこと こういう人々をちゃんと敬いなさい
それからブッダの次に行くんですね
これは仏教が前の白い文字で言ったのは
インド一般的なインド社会のしきたり
習慣 師匠敬いなさい サマンバルも敬いなさい
両親にちゃんと礼をしなさい
年上の兄弟にちゃんと挨拶しなさいとかね
それで仏教を元とプラスで一つ読んで追加して
アラハンテーセイティブーテーカタキッチェアナースウェーニハッチャマーナンアッタッドーテーナマッセーアヌッタディー
自分の幸福を目指すならば
あなた自分のアッタっていうのは有意義という意味なんですけど
あなたは有意義なことを探しているならば
私はこれはもっと柔らかい日本語にしたんですよ
自分の幸福を目指すならば
パーリ語にあるのは 君
有意義なことを求めるならば
パーリ語では有意義で送るんだけどね
煩悩根絶した安穏に達した
なすべきことを成し終えた阿羅漢に対する慢を捨てなさい
阿羅漢の前で 聖者の前で裸にならなくちゃ
裸っていうのは不幸のことじゃないんですよ
何もない人間にならなくちゃなんです
でなきゃ瞑想とか進まないんです
痛い目に遭ったことあるんだから
私は 微妙にでも自分という俺はという気持ちになっちゃうと
もう進まないんです 伝わらないんです
慢を捨てなさい この上のない存在である彼らに礼拝しなさい
それでナマッサ礼拝するっていうことはこちらに入れるんです
前のセクションはそれぞれ文脈に合わせて礼をすればいいんです
それで人類が真理を知っている人がいるならば
真理を体験している人がいるならば
見栄を張るんじゃないんです
素直になって それをして教えてもらわなくちゃいけない
それで素直になるという言葉なんですね
お釈迦様使っている言葉
こちらでニハタマーニ
ニハッチャマーニ マーナン
慢を捨てなさい 殺せなさい
はい これでエピソードはほとんど終わります
布施道に入る ジェンタの自我の錯覚が破れ預流果に達する
ブッダと喋ったら あの自我が壊れちゃったんです
すごく自由になっちゃった
自分がものすごい苦しくて
今までみんなにクタクタ言われるわ言われるわで
もう自分がめげない 頑固一歩で行くんですね
頑固一徹で行くんだけど
苦しい みんな軽蔑して
みんな 馬鹿にしてみんなを見下して
生きてはいたんだけど
仕方がなくやっていたんですね
すごく苦しいんです お釈迦様ポイントを教えたんです
君の慢だと あ 慢じゃあ楽だとわかったところで喜びに覚ったんです
心が変わったってことなんですね
わかった程度じゃないんです
今まで考えた思考パターンガクッと変わっちゃったんです
これの方が正しいと 出家して仏道歩む
だからすごいんですよ
喜びに覚って出家する
残りのこともやりますと
心の 完全たる喜らかな人間になってみると
だから本当に清らかなことを探していたんだからね
カースト制度守って こんなのないやと
修行の結果 阿羅漢果に達するんです
マルティ問題完了する
それから達した安穏について語った言葉が
今日って今日のテーマです
今日のテーマで やっと今日のテーマに入ります
それでもう尊者ですよ
今までジェンタさん若者の時とこれから全て今その師匠になるジェンタ尊者が自分がいかに安穏に達したのかともこれから語っていきます
ジャーティマデーナマットーハンボーガッサーリーエナチャサンターナワンナルーペーナマデマットーアチャーリハン
これはもう詩だからね
これから中村先生の訳をそのままパクります
面倒くさい でもこの中村訳を読んでみると
ちょっとどうかなっていうところ結構あるんです
私は生まれを誇り また財産と権威を鼻にかけ
体の色と形を大いに誇って歩き回った
麻薬中毒者のように生きていたという意味ですよ
それは中村先生の訳から出てこないニュアンスなんです
マデマットーアチャーリハンというのは
もう酔っ払っていたんだと
私は 右も左もわからない状態でいたんだと
そこは偉大なる中村師匠の訳にはないんですね
そのニュアンスが抜けちゃう
だからこれ作品でもあるし
文学的なものでもありますから
ちょっとそこは我々もパーリ語で読めますね
私は昔ね 私は生まれが偉そうな生まれだとか
財産があるんだとかね
権力まである 誰にこれほど権力あるのかと
私ほどかっこいい男いるのかとかね
そんな感じで 私は頭がいかれていたんだと
中毒状態 麻薬中毒状態でいたと
ナッタノーサマカンカンチーアティレカンチャマンニサン
アティマノーハトーバーローパッタッタドーウッシッタッチャダジョー
ウッシッタッダジョー
一人として自分に愛しいものや超え優れたものをいるとは思わず
自分こそ優れていると思う慢心のために傷つけられ
傷つけられ  傷つけられ
おらかで それ頑迷？ 頑迷で傲慢である
頑迷で傲慢であった 顔面で傲慢と訳するんだけど
このパッタッタッドっていうのはちょっと別な意味なんですね
すごい頑固ということで
ウッシッタダジョっていうのは
このすごい旗を立てていたんだっていう感じで
この旗を立てるっていうフレーズをよく使うんですね
ものすごく傲慢っていう意味で
今も我々はそのフレーズを使うんです
あの人は旗を立ててあげてるんだと言ったら
とんでもない傲慢だっていう意味なんですね
マタランピタランチアピアンニエピガルサンマティメナキンチアビーアビワデーシンマナッタッドアナダロ
母も父も そしてその他の尊敬しなければならぬとなられる人々に対してさえ
私は傲慢 顔面 尊敬の念を持たなかったために
一人も敬礼しなかった
誰にも手を合わせたことはないんだと
両親に対してすっごい性格悪かったっていうことです
俗世間だったらもう治り難い人間ですよ
お釈迦様は一言葉で治しました
ディッソアビナヤカンアッダンサーラティーナンワルッタマンタパンタネワアディッチャンビクサンガプラッカタン
そこで最上の道士を見たんだと
行者たちの最初さ ブッダが
サーラティンワルットのサーラティっていうのはこの導く人ですね
その中で先輩の方々の中で一番最上トップのブッダに会いましたと
タパンタネワアディッチャン
その師匠が太陽のごとく輝いていたんだと
それでビクサンガプラッキタン
たくさんの比丘たち 弟子たちの間で輝いていたんだと
ブッダが太陽のごとく
その様を見て マナンマダンチャチャッデッワヴィッパサンゲーナチェーダサーシラサーアビワデーシンサッバサッターナムッタマン
私は高ぶりと自惚れを捨てて
全く清らかとなった心をもって
あらゆる生き物の最上者
ブッダの流離に私は頭をつけて敬礼をしたと
だからこのジェンタ長老の言葉から見ると
ジェンタ長老がある程度学者だから自分で書いた詩だと思いますけどね
自分で歌ったいいやと思いますけど
詩だと思うんだけど いきなりブッダに敬礼したわけじゃないんです
質問して 答えいただいて
それでわかったんです
わかって 最初にこの若者がブッダに土下座をして
頭を床につけて ブッダの足を礼をする
この今のインド人はすごい命の人だったら手で触るんですね
すごいかっこよくやってますよ
私もすごいかっこいい挨拶でございますよ
先生たちだったらこうやってナマステとかなんとかないんです
皆様 インドの挨拶ナマステやと思ってるでしょ？まあいろいろありますけどね
で 何も言いません さっと手を足で足を触るんです
だから今もう頭つけるということはね
そこまではやらないんだけどね
昔の頭を足につけちゃうんです
最高の礼なんですね だから喜びに悟ってからお釈迦様にもう
礼をした可能性が大で
この本人の言葉からは読めるんです
注釈書では 私はブッダの話を聞いてすぐ話を聞く前に礼をしましたと
これちょっとおかしいやり取り
あんた質問あったら聞いてくれと言った途端
土下座するわけじゃないんです
だから質問を誰にそれはよろしいと言ったんですね
これこれこれこれでしょうと
そこで自分の自我が傲慢がなくなっちゃって
それでドカーンと 今まで誰にもやったことのない礼を
最高の敬礼をブッダにしまったよと
だから本人にとってはこれすごい出来事なんですね
人生を何点と言うんですか？ターニングポイントなんです
それと面白いことは この若者が最初に礼したのがお釈迦様だからね
今まで誰にも頭を下げたことがない
だから人格変わって悟りに達して礼をしたということなんです
アティマノーチャ オーマノー パヒーナ スサムーハタ
アスミマーノ サムッチンノー サッデーマーンヴィダーハタ
で 中村先生の訳を言ってから説明します
自分が優れているという慢心と
自分より他人が劣っているという慢心も捨てて
そして欲除いた 我ありという慢心も絶たれ
あらゆる種類の慢心は滅ぼされたと
アティマノーというのはもう自分が最高な人間であるという自我論
俺が一番偉いよという気持ちですね
オーマノーというのはヒゲマンというんですね
私はあんまり何も立場がない
これ自我が出てくるんです
全部 それはなくなったと
だから高慢も卑下ももうないんだ
それからアスミマーナ
この行目の言葉 最初のこと
アスミマーナ これってキーワードなんで
アスミっていうのはアイアムという意味なんです
マイセルフ マイセルフという気持ち自体がなくなったと
私という気持ち いわゆる皆様の言葉で言えば
自分という実感 自分という実感が綺麗に消えちゃったんです
ということは 完全に悟ったということ
阿羅漢になったということ
もう自分という実感すらもない
だから皆様も悟ったらどうなるかと疑問があるでしょ？だから本当に悟ったらそうなるんです
自分という実感さえも消えちゃうんです
消えたらどうなるのかと妄想してみてください
だって修行したくないでしょうに
はい 司祭さんの子 ジェンタ長老
作者の名前 で 六つの儀礼
それで終わり 次に行きます
もう一人の坊さん待ってますから
差別の被害者の立場 ソネータ長老
これで注釈しようではない
いろんなエピソードから言っちゃうと日が暮れると思います
スニータテーラワーダだったら偈の数が多すぎる
だからスニータ長老の歌だけで読んで伝しましょう
ニーチャ クラム ニ ジャートーハン ダリッドー アッパ ポージャノーヒーナ カンマン ママン アースィ アホーシン プッパ チャッドーコー
私は卑しい家に生まれ
読めない  家業が卑しくて
家業  いえ上の  卑しい家に生まれ
貧しく  貧しく  財とぼしく
財とぼしく 私は家業が卑しくて
不浄物の製造者であった
これ極端ですよ バラモンのジェンタさんが社会の一番トップの社会の一番底にいるのはスニータさんなんです
便所掃除なんです 仕事は
これ便所掃除する人はカーストの人々と会ってはならない
顔を合わせてはならない
だから 大きな後ろなどなどで住んでいる人々は
あちらこちらで便所ありますけど
で 暗い内 内 内 後ろから家に入って
全部便所だけに行って
だいたいインド文化ではこの便所は家の中にはないんです
アウトハウスですね で
だから家に入らない どんなすごい立派な人であっても
宮殿みたいに家があっても
部屋家族がいくらあったっても
全部便所だけは家に作らない
これはすごいカースト壊れます
だから我々から見ればもうおかしいんだけどね
便というのはどこにあるんです？自分の体の中にあるもんです
それで言ったら それで自分のカーストはとっくに潰れてますけどね
だから宗教価値観に入れるとあまりにもバカバカらしくなるんです
だから家に家の恵みが出ていくんですよ
ラクシュミさんが だから便所は外に作るんです
それでスニータカースト
スニータさんのカーストの人々は暗い時来て
顔を見せないでさっさと便所の中を見せないで
行ったり来たりするようにはで作っているんですね
行って あれでてんびんであれを持って街の外から持っていくんです
[笑い]ジグッチトマヌッサナンパリブートーチャワンビトニーチャンマママナンカリットワネワンディッサンバフカンジャナン人々に忌み嫌われ
軽蔑され これは罵る  罵られたが
罵られたが 私は心を低くして多くの人々を敬礼した
だから逆ですね 愛すは愛すと言ったら間違えるだろう
全体長老が若い時 誰にも敬礼して
ソニータ長老が 僧侶がどんな人間見てももう敬礼敬礼敬礼
それでも馬鹿にされる
ちけえとか顔を出す なぜ目にあうようなところに来たんですかと
汚い奴出ていけとかね
そこまで侮辱されても自分の仕事をしなくちゃいけない
そういうことは仕事をしなそういたってもカーストシステムだから
そうすると食べるもの何もなくなっちゃうんです
決して豊かになれない
ほんのわずかもらうだけ
それでもどこか便所のところに置いておくでしょうね
で カースト制度だから
この大地主の家から米とかなんとかもらわなくても
便所を洗わなくちゃいけない
便所掃除しなくちゃいけない
だからカースト制度そのものが宗教になっていくんですね
昨日便所へ行っちゃうんだけどね
まあもう米も何も野菜も何も入れとかなかったんだからね
今日は行きません ストやりますと
これは不可能ですよ だから普通人間
神様にいろんなものをお願いするでしょ
神様何もやってくれないでしょ
神社に行って いろいろ教会に行ってお願いしてもしても何もやってくれません
だからといって拝むことをやめる
どうか神様子宝に恵まれ
どうかいい縁に恵まれますようにと
いい縁って何もないとかね
だからって神を裏切らないんですね
面白いんですね 私だけですかね
行き先でやらなかったら
もうだいたいお坊さんたちスリランカ昔もいたんですか？スリランカでもいろいろ神神信仰してますけどね
だから偶然的に何か問題やっちゃうと
神のところに行ってね
こういうことになってんだからね
なんとかやってくださいと
やってくれなかったらものすごい侮辱するんです
てめえ何やと うちらがこんなに困ってるのに目が見えるかいと
めっちゃくちゃ侮辱して帰る
これ仏教だけかなとは思いますけどね
そういうエピソード 自分の国では結構あるんです
私も気に入らなかったら侮辱しますけど
大体スリランカにいるいろいろする神々の礼っていうのをね
やっぱり言ってる やってくれますよ
ちゃんと 頼まなくたってよくわかってね
ちゃんとやってくれる
すぐわかるんですね 何々さんがね
やってくれるんだから
じゃあありがとうと だからソニータさんがやっぱりね
便所掃除しなくちゃいかん
いかに軽蔑されても 罵られても
かわいそうでしょうね
これ宗教になってるんだから
アッタアッタダサーシンサンブッダンビクサンガプラッカチャンパビサンタンマハーヴィーランマガダーナントゥルッタマン
特に私は正しく悟った人にして偉大な勇者
勇者 ブッダですね 修行者の群れに取り巻かれてマガダ国の首都に入ったのを見た
実際エピソードが別にあって
お釈迦様がソニータが素晴らしい人格者だと分かっていて
わざと出たんです 街に
お釈迦様はマガダ国で
で 首都の外に住んでるんですね
マガダ国ででっかい祇園精舎がありましたからね
すごい大きいんです で
街は別で 町の外を歩いていくと
だいたい一般の方々は目覚めて朝用意始める時
お釈迦様が街に確保して入るんです
この日でお釈迦様はかなり朝早く
いわゆるこの便所掃除屋さんが来る時間狙って行ったんです
それはスニルタさんはトカゲスニルタ尊者が解かれていないんですね
解らずわかったことでしょう
スニルタさんがもう太陽が出るともういないんだから街に
街から出て この不可触民族が住む部落があるんだから
その中にある それから出てはいけない
人々は出入ったり来たり
仕事をしたりするところへ行ってはいけない
買い物もできない ババしたら殴られちゃいますからね
だから貧困といったらもう信じられない貧困なんです
スニルタさんがその時はスニルタさんですけど
まだ国にあったダーシンサンブッダん人々に有益を教えてくれるブッダ
比丘さんが来られて比丘たちと一緒に
街に入って帰るのを見まったようです
相当朝暗い時なんです
ニッキピットアナ ディアバンガン ワンディトゥン ウパサンカミン マメワ アヌカンパエ アッターシ プルスットモ
私は天秤棒を捨ててブッダを敬礼するために近づいた
人々の斎場者は私を付き込んで立ち止まっていた
これでこの方の心が変わっちゃったんです
お釈迦様はバラモンカーストよりも上のカーストなんです
これはインド中教えられているんです
そこで普段はスニルタさんが人間見たら敬礼する
人間見たら敬礼したっても
ただどうしようもなく避けない時は敬礼する
でないとむしろ殴られていくかも
敬礼したのに相手に殴られる可能性もあります
手じゃないんで手では触りません
自分のそれで殴ることもまた履かなくちゃかんだからね
何か手に取ったもので殴ってそれそれで出てそんな感じなんですね
誰もスニルタさんのために待つっていうことは一切人間の中であり得ないことなんです
そこでブッダが遠く来ると
この人は敬礼しなくちゃいけなくなってくる
お釈迦様はちゃんと待っているんですね
自分のために  [背景音楽]やっと生まれて初めて人間扱いされたんです
態度で これもインドの一番トップのカーストの方
またもう結構びっくりしたチームいたんだから
堂々たる姿で来るでしょう
来るって 師匠と弟子たちで来る場合はかなり態度でかいんですよ
で ちゃんとこの人を来てる
挨拶 ワンディットワサットノパードエカマンタンテトータダパッバチンパッパッジャンアハマヤーチンサッバサッバーナムッタマン
死のおあしに敬礼して一方一方の側に立った時
あらゆる生き物のうちの最上者に対して出家したいと願った
これで結構省略されていますね
で エピソードでは 便所捨てたじゃなくて
便所見せてはいけないんだからそれを置いておいて
あと敬礼しようと待ったら
お釈迦様はちゃんとスリッパで待っていて
そしてその人の前に立って
自分にとってはもう生まれてから初めての経験
人間として自分を見てもらったこと
お釈迦様は何やっているの？そんなことやって
出家したらどうですかと聞いたそうです
道を捨てたらどうですか？と
この大胆革命的なことを言うんで
これ革命なんです これカースト変えられないんです
あの人々にはどんな宗教組織にも入れない
入れてくれない 死ぬまで便所掃除しなさいと
給料をもらうかもらわないか関係ない
飢え死になってもいいんじゃないかと
飢え死になっても それでアンタはもう神様の義務を果たったことになるんだ
そういう話ですから だからあんた
あんたね お釈迦様 あんたこの道を変えたらどうですか？別の生き方なんか
例えば出家すると だからそれは無理ですと
私は受け入れる宗教組織がありませんと
で 私のところ大丈夫ですよと
私のところ大丈夫と言ったら
だったらぜひお願いします
出家したいんだと 受け入れるなら
タトーカーニコーサッターサッバローカーヌカンパコーエイヒビクーティマンアーハーサーメーアースッタサンタダ
そこで憐れみ深いし あらゆる世間の慈愛者は
言うかね ちょっと意味が野蛮な悪いんだけどね
カーリコウサッタ人々憐れむ憐れむ師匠がサッバローカーヌカンピコ
すべての生命のことを心配するブッダが
ブッダが一部の人じゃなくて
一切生命を心配するから
エイヒビク うん じゃあいいよと一言言ったんです
私は出家して欲求に達します
いいですよ はい OK 終わり
[笑い]エイヒビクっていうのはエイヒっていうのは来たり
カンビクビクよ おいでよと
このお釈迦様の一言葉でビクなんです
ビクとして来てっていうのは
このサンガの組織に入ってくださいと
その権力はお釈迦様にしかないんです
我々は人をビクとして認定する場合は
これを会議でやらなくちゃいけないんです
最低人五 六人は必要なんです
お坊さんたち 四年でもやるのは難しいんです
インドでやるならば インド中央インドでやるならば人が集まらないと
地方ではまあ少ない数字でできます
それでビクたちのビクたちサンガが決まってる
全部もうプレイス決まってるプレイスで
それで議会のような感じで提案して
こういう人が出家したいと思ってる
で どうですかと 資格あるかないか調べましょうと
では私は調べますと 言っていただいて
資格も決まり文句で これこれどうですか
これどうで これどう聞いたら
本人がはいはいはいというので四回ぐらい
いい二回ぐらいやりますよね
それで終わり それでまたビクサンガに報告する
この人は調べました 資格全部揃っていると
ですから読みましょうかと
サンガの中に そこでそこで永避という言葉を使います
入ってくださいと 入ってくださいったって比丘じゃないんです
要するに その人がまだ比丘でないんだけど
比丘の間に入れちゃって
もうまた提案 合掌行って三回繰り返して賛成かないかと聞くんですね
それで誰も賛成しませんということを仏教ではやりません
黙っているので ではみんな万場一致賛成しましたので
この人は比丘として認定いたします
決定終わり 時間かかる
まあまあ 大体私の本山でやる場合は
二十分 二十五分かかる
ものすごい早口でやりますからね
儀式には二十分 二十五分ですけど
これ一日かかりますよ
で お釈迦は来なさい 出家をしようと私に告げた
これが私の出家であった
来なさい 出家をしようと言っただけで
もう比丘戒を受けたことになります
だから あっという間にお釈迦様はまだ町に入りました
その人さんに出会った
それでちょっと話し合って
いいよ はい 出ましょうと
終わり それから比丘 ソハンエコアランヤスミンビハラントアタンディトアカシンサットアチャランヤターマンオーワディジノ
勝者ブッダが私に教えられた通りに
私はただ一人で森に住み
師の言葉を実行した だからすべて革命的なことだから教えてるのに
教えた通りに私は一人でずっと修行しましたと
えらい真剣に修行したんです
だってありえないチャンスですからね
ラッティヤパタマンヤーマンパッバジャーティマヌッサラン
プッバジャーティマヌッサラン
ラッティヤマッジマンヤーマンディッバチャッコムヴィソゥディン
ラッティヤパッチメヤーメータムッカンダンパターディン
私は夜の--これ読めない
初？ 初稿  初稿 初稿において先生を思い起こしということは
この自分の過去生をしっかりと読める神通を獲得したんですね
瞑想で 過去生で何々やっていたのかどうかね
だから先生っていうのは思い起こしじゃないんです
だから学者だからね ブッダってただのおじさんの一人と言っているとね
超能力あるとは認めません天変落旋要因だ
これはこの過去生をしっかりと思い出して言うことができる能力をつけたんですね
夜の中行において優れた透視力を極め
この透視力ディッパチャク天眼というんです
一般日本語でね 普通の人間に見えない神々
いろんな他の生命のこととか
見えるようになりました
夜の五行において無知の塊を砕いた
一晩で まあ修行しただろうと思いますけど
このちゃんと瞑想の本当に瞑想に入っちゃうと
この瞑想もいろんなランクありますから
この悟るステージに入っちゃうと大体一晩で終わります
一晩かかったのは このいろいろ超能力も全て出た
その瞑想もやっていたんだから
現代はもうそういう時代じゃなくて
このちゃんと道に入っちゃうと
大体分秒で悟りに達してます
もう今ヴィパッサナー瞑想だけでね
サマッディ瞑想まで教えませんから
だからあの ちょっと元に戻します
無知の塊を砕いたっていうことは
完全に阿羅漢になったっていう意味なんですね
カトーラッティアーヴィヴァサーネ ヴィヴァサーネ スリヤ スッガマナン パティ インドゥブラフマーチアーガンター ママ ナマッシン スッパンジェリ
これ美しいですけどね
それから夜の明け方もう光がもう見え始めているんです
太陽がの上がるところ
インドラ天と梵天がやってきて
私に合掌し 拝拝してこう言った
すごいでしょう インドラ天というのはこの神々の王様なんですね
神々は六次元 六つありますけど
この一と二の天界の王様がインドラと
これヒンドゥーの言葉ですけど
仏教では別なサッカという言葉使いますね
あのインドラっていうのはこの王という意味なんですね
本当は ブラフマーっていうのはブラマン教の神様なんですね
そういう神様いるんですけど
ヒンドゥー教で言ってることは嘘だけでね
だから神様いないわけでも本当にいないわけでもない
だからただ普通人間の中にも霊名であってね
で 降りてきて礼をするんですね
だからそこはちょっとスミードさんって人間の世界ではダメですかね
人間扱いされないと そこでブラマン人も神様として梵天を拝んでるんですね
ブラマン人にももう手に届かないすごい存在なんです
直々来ている様子ね この人
悟ってから だからそういう方々も待っていたんです
このブッダのこの人類にこのものすごい道を教えるんだと
カースト差別ではなく
道徳世界をちゃんと教えと誓ってるんだから
応援しているんですね
はい そろそろ終わりと思います
ナモーテ プリサージャンネ ナモーテ プリスッタマ ヤッサ テ アーサワー キーナ ダッキーネ ヨーシ マーリセ
人々のうちで生まれたよき者よ
ナモーテ プリサージャンネ アージャンネ プリサージャージャンネっていうのはこのスンメット意味なんです
馬の中でサラベットというね
それは人間のことは人間の中で一番優れた人
あなたに礼拝しますと
ナモーテ プリスッタマ
人間の最上の人に 最上の者よ
あなたに礼拝します あなたの穢れが滅びている
いわゆる煩悩がなくなっている
もう穢れがない そこでこのバラモン人も穢れをなくそうと頑張ってるでしょ
だから彼らが思ってる穢れて迷信で
低いカーストの人を触ったら自分のカーストが穢れると
ブッダが思ってる穢れっていうのは心の煩悩なんですね
だからみんな穢れてるんです
そこを清らかにする道を教えてるんですね
[終始背景音楽]尊い人よ
あなたは供養を受けるに値する人です
この供養を受けるに値するというのは
もう全ての生命はあなたに礼をするべきですよ
本物の聖者ですよと タトージッソアナマンサッターデーヴァサンガプラッカタンシタンパートンカリットワナイマッタンアパーシタ
それからシワ 知ってお釈迦様
私が神々に神々の群れに囲まれているのを見て
お釈迦様見たこのスニッタ長老の周りに神々が群がっているんですね
寄っているんですね 見て
ほほ笑んだんです ブッダの努力叶ったんだから
人間は平等である 迷信一切なく
汚れは心にあると ブッダの道を歩めば汚れがなくなるんだよ
それでこのスニッタ大尊者がお釈迦様に素直に言った通りに修行して阿羅漢になったんですね
だからお釈迦様がほほ笑むんですね
よかったと お釈迦様が偈を歌う
お釈迦様 タペーナブラフマ
これはただのブッダ仏教ですね
タペーナブラフマチャリーナーサンヤメーナダメーナチャーエーテーナブラームノホーティエータンブラームナムクタマン
熱心な修行と清らかな行いと制御と調教と
これらによってバラモンである
これが最上のバラモンである
タパっていうのはいつでも仲間の先生は修行という風に訳しますからね
ブラフマチャリアっていうのは清らかな生き方
世間から離れた生き方をする
サンヤメーナダマ自分を戒めて制御する
それだったらバラモンになりますよと
ただのバラモンじゃなくて
本物の バラモンという人の場合は清らかな人という意味で取っているんです
あ 終わった スニッタテーラワーダサカニパート
で 私はなんか余計な疑問を持つんだけど
スニッタ尊者が不可触民族でしたから
文字は習えないでしょう
学問ゼロでしょう 悟ったことは確かに悟りましたけど
当時のマケドニアの言語を喋ったでしょう
お釈迦様はいくつかの国の言語を喋られたんだからね
お釈迦様は大体十六 十八ぐらいの言語を喋られた
私が思うのは ソニータ尊者は尊者は尊者確かに
宿かけますかね すっくれますかね
これはもう他のお坊さんたちがすごく興味持ったんですね
ソニータ出家しただけでお坊さんたちがすごいびっくり
一緒にいなさいと 仲間同じだと
だからお釈迦様自分たちのカースト感覚はあったでしょうしね
でも悟ってない人々にとってはすごいきついことなんですね
悟った方々は問題ないんだけど
これ ブッダ直々出家させたんだから
かなり格が高いんです
だから一言も言えない
ブッダ直々出家認めたら下すところないんです
そういう比丘たちに対して一言もあの坊さんたちには言えないんです
で だからお坊さんたちは
でもあなたはもうどんな人をどんな生まれ
あれこれと聞いちゃうと
素直に私は本当はこういう不可触民族の人で
ものすごい惨めな生き方していて
人間なら誰にでも礼を信じてする身分で
で ブッダに会ってこうなりましたよ
今はもう私には神通があるしね
過去世見られる能力あるし
天眼あるし 完全たるヴィパッサナーに達してますと
能力があります そこはまとめて偉大なる阿羅漢だから信任されたっていうことも考えられないわけじゃないんです
ジェンタ尊者の場合はなんか自分の言葉でしょうね
それはなんとなく感じるんですね
はい これで今日のお話は終わり
で カーストの一番トップの人と一番底の人
ブッダに出会って両方が解脱に達する
カーストは意味がないということに
でも このカーストによって精神的に束縛っていうのはそれぞれ違うんですね
一人は加害者で 傲慢張ってものすごい精神的に苦しんでる結局は
一人は被害者にやられっぱなしで精神的に苦しんでいる
どちらにも苦しみは同じなんです
自我なんです 自分がいると決めつければ何のこともないんです
だからポイントは同じです
マイセルフという気持ちが消えちゃったんです
ジェンタ長老もソニータ長老も
だから世間的なものはどうでもいいんです
はい 話は終了です どうもありがとうございます
基本でかなりたくさんあるんですが
文字だともう 私の案がつくて
それが一つ目 二つ目は
三つ目は これはネットワークニューラルネットワーク
どれがいい？その三つだったらどれがいい？ ありがとう
一番 一番 じゃあこれの方向で
あとはこの前先生と対話していただいた映画監督の京田さんなんですけど
対談の方まとめられる前に彼アメリカにちょっとマインドフルネス瞑想の講師を受けてすごく良かったって言ってました
ぜひスマナサーラ長老からの指導を受けて
それについてかなり深い
六月にちょっと行こうと思うんだけど
例えば午後二時半から九時くらいまでっていう夕方までの感じで
ありがとうございます
お願いします お呼ばれします